cette mission financée par l'état va
parcourir en 18 mois vingt mille
kilomètres à travers l'afrique à partir
d'écrits photos et autres archives ce
documentaire suit les traces d'une
expédition menée par l'explorateur
maurice grille houle et l'écrivain
michel leiris contre dakar-djibouti de
1931 à 1933
une expédition pour aller à la rencontre
des peuples des pays africains colonisés
par la france découvrir leur culture et
collecter les objets dont ils se servent
3006 artfact seront ainsi envoyées au
musée d'ethnographie à paris qui va
devenir le musée de l'homme ce que j'ai
ici dans différents films c'était de
raconter tant que je le pouvais
l'histoire de certains objets comme le
kono qu'elle des pièces maîtresses du
musée du quai branly qui est un très bel
objet nick est aussi une charge
rituel sacré très très importante mon
coeur bat très fort car depuis le
scandale dit hier je perçois avec plus
d'acuité l'énormité de ce que nous
commettons le vol de ce qu nos boules
vers ce michel leiris dans les carnets
de route deviendront un livre à son
retour à paris juin 1933 le butin de la
mission 3600 objet a été légalement mise
en scène par jean rivière ce
documentaire soulève l'enjeu des objets
d'art africain dérobé à ses peuples la
moindre des choses ce serait d'en parler
et justement ce qui me choque moi c'est
que dans le musée du quai branly comme
dans d'autres musées d'ailleurs en
europe on ne raconte pas
réellement l'histoire de ces objets aux
tons la connaît pourquoi ne pas raconter
le donné l'extrême et michel leiris soie
carton à côté d'objets kono exposé au
musée du quai branly ou disant voilà il
a été volé dans quelles conditions et
sait comment regarder aujourd'hui ces
objets orphelins le réalisateur est
favorable à la restitution de ces objets
surtout ceux qui ont des valeurs
religieuses et culturelles ils viennent
de là ils sont utiles la barre beaucoup
plus que chez nous le message c'est ça
c'est partageons avec les pays du gué de
ces objets
l'élection par son la restituer si c'est
souhaité ans on va faire connaître leurs
conditions d'acquisition s'est senti un
échange et une parole ouverte et assumée
et sur ces questions
des questions qui nous plonge dans la
plaie toujours béantes de la
colonisation il c'est catherine françois
radio canada montréal